we live in this consumerism culture it's
the reality okay hater to love it we
live in this culture where it's all
about the instagram flex what nice stuff
can i have what can i show off on
instagram what does my friend post on
instagram do i have nice stuff like them
and this is the system that we're in and
it's good if you understand the system
because now you can be a producer in
this system it's bad if you don't
understand the system because now you're
the one being screwed over by the system
and so what i'm trying to get it is
instead of trying to fight the system
learn the system that way you can use it
to your advantage this is what financial
education is all about because
this is how it works it's like gravity
okay it's around us it is there it is
happening it has been happening and it's
going to continue to happen even after
you're gone so you might as well learn
it that way you can make the best
situation for yourself for your family
and your community because
you know i grew up being told
don't worry about money don't talk about
money money is bad money is evil and it
rots people this is the the mindset that
i grew up with my parents are immigrants
from a state in india called punjab
they came to this country with very
little my dad had less than a hundred
dollars when he came to america
he didn't speak english life was very
different in punjab especially then they
grew up very poor my grandparents were
refugees
they got kicked out of their homes when
they were teenagers they my grandfather
literally slept on the streets because
he had no home
because there was like riots looting all
this stuff happening he had a fight for
his life literally
and with that type of immigrant mindset
you want your kids to become successful
and what does that translate to
well for my parents like many other
immigrant parents it's your kid should
become a doctor
why a doctor because when you're a
doctor it comes with a lot of prestige
uh it comes with the status
and it comes with a big salary and
safety and so you assume that if you're
a doctor you're at the top of the food
chain everything is going to be fine
you're going to live a great life and
you're not going to have to worry about
things like money
like your parents did
and so that's the whole mindset
and that's what i was told don't worry
about all these things don't worry about
investing and all this other stuff that
my parents had no idea about instead
just go and become a doctor because now
you're gonna be
great and everything's gonna be just
fine
well
along the way
i realized
that there's a lot more to life than
becoming a doctor there's a lot more to
money than just earning a big salary
and that was the turning point for me to
become financially educated because
unfortunately
many people
follow a career just for the money many
people become doctors just for the money
i almost became one of those people
now don't get me wrong i love helping
people it is a part of my culture and
it's a part of me
i i love helping people it is something
that morally i want to do
now medicine
is you're helping people but you're also
getting paid for it right it's not
community service but being a doctor
like you are doing it for payment right
so exactly if i want to help as many
people as i can as a doctor this is
where my my brainstream started to get
pulled upon
i want to help people as a doctor but i
also want to maximize my revenue because
i'm starting to think financially well
what does that mean does that mean that
i'm going to have to maximize my
patience perhaps sacrifice the quality
of work that i do
but morally that doesn't seem right so
i'm starting to face this like big war
internally where
maybe i'm not doing this for the right
reasons and that's also kind of when i
fell upon financial education and
investing in entrepreneurship and i
realized wow
there's so many other ways to earn
and there's so many other ways for me to
give so it's that difference and it all
starts with the mindset
of
how do we look at money how does money
play an aspect in our lives and how do
we
want money to flow in our lives
and this is this is all regarding you
know starts with that mindset this is
like what you build your financial
education intelligence and standpoint
from is like what's your mindset and
then what's your lifestyle so what i'm
hearing is that
you love what you do so much and you've
clearly had so much traction and success
as a result
so it
do you
do you get energy from doing what you do
yes
and what's funny is i think people see
me as successful because of the brand
that i built on youtube uh what's called
minority mindset and what's funny is
when i started minority mindset
i had no intention of making money
i was doing it as a hobby because i was
working on a different company at the
time which was my real
time commitment and my like
i don't want to say purpose but that's
where my energy was going
i was running a sock company that i
created
and during the launch i got screwed over
i got scammed by a fake marketing
company they took a few thousand dollars
and i got upset um
but you know i think when someone has
the entrepreneurial bug you're like okay
i'm upset let me go to the gym now what
do i do
and for me that was it was like okay you
know either i'm gonna sit here and cry
about it or you know let me do something
because
entrepreneurship is one of those things
that i had to do it in secret because if
my parents found out that i was running
you know businesses they were not going
to be happy because it had nothing to do
with me becoming a doctor
true story so i ran all of my early
businesses from high school through
college in secret
and
when i launched the saw company i got
screwed over and i was like just
frustrated because i had no support i
never had a mentor i never knew kind of
where to go i would always get my
education from books and i hated reading
books
until i started reading business books
so that was when i was like you know
let me try to create something to help
other
people like me so i put out a class on
this platform called udemy on how to
launch a business without getting
screwed over i put it out for like seven
bucks i don't really care about making
money it was just a way for me to like
put out some education to help people
who were in a similar situation because
i got screwed over so
the class did really well and i did it
under the alias minority mindset just
because i thought that i thought
differently than the majority of people
that's awesome and yeah and the class
well and people were like oh my god this
is so cool can you create a social media
page
i was like sure so i created an
instagram page called minority mindset
where i essentially did the same thing i
made posts on like just basic things
that i wish i knew about you know
business and money management and stuff
like that
and
i was making these posts on instagram
and people would send me dms and
comments saying would you mind starting
a blog because like this is really long
and it's hard to read on instagram like
just to start a blog and i was like
you don't want me to start a blog like
english is my second language
is you're not gonna enjoy that so
no but i don't mind talking so i'll make
youtube videos and then slowly minority
mindset started to grow
and i made the decision to shut down my
other company and focus on minority
mindset not because i was making more
money but because i enjoyed it way more
when you do your passion and then kind
of for me i led with value and the money
came kind of followed
and that's why here at the minority
mindset companies our core one of our
core values is lead with value always
just provide value and then
focus on that and the money will follow
i kind of want to distill this down to
like a nugget for people because
what i've found is that the things that
are really that are your purpose and
calling and that you'll do really well
are the things that give you energy
versus take energy it's the things that
you love and that fuel you and that you
that you do as your side hustle like you
kind of did that they talk about so much
in the business world a side hustle
that's your real purpose and that's a
good navigation tool to know like what
you should and shouldn't do
exactly and you know we kind of have a
running joke here in our office here
because i don't drink coffee um i i
drink tea and my team here has like a
running joke that if i had coffee like i
would just go off the walls of berserk
they keep the coffee away from me do
they think you'd double your output i i
did i think they think i'd double my
output and i'd require double from them
as well so
yeah like keep the coffee away
what is money that's like i have these
fantasies about living um off the grid
and exchanging services for
for life like what is
why couldn't that be possible yeah and
so
what's money that's a great question
what's its purpose yeah
where did it come from
that's a multi-part question so let's
let's go like maybe a little bit
philosophical to a little bit more
technical cool so philosophically money
is freedom we don't care about having
dollars we don't care about having cash
like that doesn't do anything for us
like if you had 10 million dollars of
cash but the cash no one is there to buy
it and you can't buy anything with it it
doesn't do anything it's just a piece of
paper that's taking up space so we don't
technically want that cash we want what
money can buy which for many of us is
freedom uh sure maybe you might think oh
but i want a lambo i want this i want
that yeah i mean those things can be
nice and money can buy you that too but
for most people we want freedom we want
the freedom to be able to live our lives
the way we want we want the freedom to
wake up when we want we want the freedom
to work on the things that we want we
want the freedom to buy our spouse the
things that they want we want the
freedom to send our kids to school where
they want we want the freedom to go to
the best doctors that we can we want the
freedom to eat where we want and we want
the freedom to go on vacation wherever
we want it's the freedom that money can
buy that most of us are after
now if we go a little bit deeper
into what is money technically
this is where money
can get a little bit confusing and this
goes into a lot of kind of economic
concepts that most of the times we're
never taught
and this goes into now what is
money because money can either be a
means of exchange or it can be a store
of value so i'm gonna try not to get too
technical and too confusing but what
that means is
if you had ten thousand dollars with the
cash
and you dug this into your backyard
today
in ten years or twenty years
is that ten thousand dollars gonna buy
you the same they can same stuff that i
can buy you today
and the answer is no
now
why well the ques the answer is because
our money what we think of as money on
paper dollars isn't the best store of
value our money what we call money loses
value every single day because of
something called inflation so what we
call money isn't the best store of value
but it's a good currency meaning means
of exchange if you have ten thousand
dollars in your hand you can go to the
apple store buy a nice macbook you can
buy a laptop you can buy you know
whatever you want to buy because you
have that money to do that
so this is where
old money we'll call old money things
like physical gold your traditional
money
serves a better store of value because
it takes time effort and labor to mine
an ounce of gold
and that representation of that time
effort and labor is
through the physical gold so the
physical gold serves as a better store
of value
but it's not a very good means of
exchange because now if you go to
lululemon or you go to apple or you go
to gucci and you walk in with a gold bar
and you say can i buy this they're going
to look at you really confused because
they don't know what to do with that
maybe somebody will take it because
they're they're all but financially
educated and they'll say oh yeah i'll
take this but most people are going to
say no
[Music]
you